it's a long and difficult route up to
the mountains of Panay the mountains
ascend more than 1000 meters there are
no roads the only way up is on foot only
a few corners of forest remain the rest
has been logged or burned down replaced
by rice paddies other crops and grassy
hillsides in general this forest is
their habitat the home of the wildlife
species and biodiversity so once it is
disturbed or gone their home will be
gone as well so it's very important
there are still many native species in
the forest the two environmentalists are
especially interested in the rafflesia
it's the world's largest flower and is
very rare it gives off a scent like
rotting flesh that draws the insects
which pollinate the flowers endemic here
once button sit they'll be done here in
the island you can't find them in other
places in other islands in the
Philippines and in the whole world so
it's very important to protect this area
especially that there are a lot of
threats around this area threats to the
biodiversity not only in this specific
species but to the whole biodiversity
estou the village of kario is about two
hours away on foot the people are
farmers and subsist from agriculture
most live in wood huts it's a simple way
of life and at first glance it seems
unchanging but traces of last year's
typhoon haiyan are still visible
everywhere once this was a small complex
for visitors
the typhoon destroyed it all homes a
cafeteria a small pond all swept away
and the environmentalists find more
signs of improper reforesting instead of
using indigenous species they planted
quick growing exotic species they have
shallow root systems and can't withstand
a typhoon if your aim is to restore the
forest then we should use endemic
indigenous species so that it could help
biodiversity and also the protective
services of the forest is there because
if you use exotics and after 20 years
here comes a big typhoon and they will
all fall down
and all the efforts of restoring is the
school also took a beating Haeju Molina
which is not a native species the heavy
winds of high on knocked it over onto
the roof now the school is missing a
classroom damage like this can be found
across the entire country there's no
telling when money will come in for
repairs
but first the tree has to be removed
reforestation is an important issue here
to make it work the villagers need to
learn more about the forest and what
species are needed the initiative is
supported by the German Agency for
International Cooperation or GI Z they
developed plans for how the land around
the village should be used whenever
possible the hillsides around the
village is to be planted with new trees
and other native plants the men head out
in groups they plant seedlings that they
grew in their own nurseries they've
learned that it's the root system that
counts the roots are what holds the soil
in place it's quite simple if we plant
enough trees here in the area then it
will protect us and our village
now we know that the roots will secure
the soil on the hillside and then we
won't have as many mudslides so planting
trees helps everyone but reforestation
doesn't bring in any extra income the
Vicente family has specialized in
growing ginger they used to sell the
ginger roots at the market but now they
turn the roots into tea the powdered tea
fetches a much better price than just
the roots I sell a lot of the tea I go
from house to house with it
when I come back my daughter asks me how
it went and I tell her it went very well
the Panna initiative also shows people
how to survive and better their lives
without destroying the last remaining
forested areas
the forest is also a habitat for animals
this is a breeding station in
neighboring Milan pi a young Hawk eagle
is being nursed back to health
fishermen found it down by the ocean
they think it may have been swept out by
the typhoon but it's actual habitat is
the forest today it's headed home after
10 more minutes it's time the young bird
is released into freedom everything is
carefully documented the hawk eagle is
an endangered species on the island the
young bird pays no attention it's
getting used to its refound freedom in
one of the few remaining forests of pond
I